but I had to do something I had to
protect or not for getting something now
we'll give you a hint she's evil
vindictive and as far as we know she can
still fit in the palm of your hand we're
talking about your mom Maleficent is she
still a lizard if so why didn't you turn
her back she may be evil but she's still
your mom are you going to let her stay
in lizard form forever
fans are wondering where Maleficent is
and why we haven't seen her
transformation back to our original form
and that's not all fans are wishing
would have happened in descendant 3
while the latest villain Kid movie was
amazing it left fans wanting more here
are 10 things fans wanted to happen in
descendants three consequences for
Audrey a tease had it right when he said
that a girl from auradon can get away
with just about anything
meanwhile the villains are trapped on
the Isle for crimes way less evil than
Audrey's Audrey caused a lot of trouble
for auradon but instead of being held
accountable for her actions now
apologize to her
Hades is right that's not fair at all
Zuma and Harry
seriously why didn't you men Harry get
together in d3 if Disney had been paying
attention to how hard fans were shipping
Puma they would have let these two get
together in the latest film instead
Harry was just trying to hook up with
every girl he saw and when he went for
uma she rejected him disappointing for
fans
we all saw those sparks flying between
Harry and uma during her what's my name
number indi - what kids Disney dragon
hull we've seen a lot of word on Pratt
but what about the school on the Isle of
the Lost
in the novel's dragon Hall is a school
founded by dr. Vasily a it aims to teach
the villain kids how to learn from the
mistakes of the villains who came before
them but there was no mention of the
school in the films
fans think this was a missed opportunity
dr. Vasily a while we're on the subject
of dr. Vasily a many viewers thought his
part was way too small in descendants 3
he hardly had any lines you make sure
you get you
we know from The Princess and the Frog
as well as from the novels that he has
an interesting story
so why was his part so small in the film
maybe Disney couldn't fit it all into
one movie but with all of the magical
characters in the books series and films
there are plenty of chances for
spin-offs Lonnie and J Lonnie and J were
total relationshipgoals and descendants
too they supported each other through it
all however there was no mention of
Lonnie in descendants three at the very
least there could have been a phone call
between Lonnie and J and D three similar
to Chad and Audrey's phone conversation
in d - alas we all missed one of our
favorite characters and J was without
his true love in descendants three the
wedding descendants three starts with
Ben's unforgettable proposal to mal for
her hand in marriage
fans were giddy at the idea of a royal
wedding but Disney didn't deliver
leaving everyone disappointed
we loved the ending in descendants three
and we can see why they steered away
from having another ceremony at the end
of the film like they did in the
previous two still we're dying to know
what Mouse wedding dress would have
looked like you know Evie would have
designed it to look fabulous reunion
with the core four and their villain
parents we all danced in front of our
TVs when they opened the barrier and
saying break this down all the villains
came across the bridge to dance with all
of the people of Oregon for the final
number and it was pure magic
but some of the characters were missing
Jaina Carlos mentioned Cruella but we
never get to see her in fact none of the
core fors original villain parents from
d1 made an appearance a Carlos and Jade
duet mal and Evie had the phenomenal
duet in descendants - called the space
between this left fans wanting another
best buddy song in d3 Jay and Carlos
were like brothers and they are both
acrobatic dancers a funky upbeat song
that allowed them to show off their epic
moves while celebrating their friendship
would have been amazing to watch it
would have given grieving fans a
much-needed connection to Cameron boys
who left us much too soon
Maleficent the lizard speaking of og
villain parents where on earth is
Maleficent
last time we saw her she was still a
lizard Indy to the mouth took her back
to the aisle during her little rebellion
tour in d3 Matt was able to turn back
into herself once the barrier reversed
Audrey's old lady curse since there is
no magic on the aisle it stands to
reason that Maleficent would have
returned her original form once mal
brought her back to the Isle yet we
never get to see her
Katie's and Maleficent showdown the duet
between Hades and mal made us yearn for
a showdown between her evil parents fans
are crying for an epic battle between
Hades and Maleficent just imagine the
blue and purple flames filling up
ordered on skies that would have been
amazing but as we said before sadly
Maleficent was nowhere to be found in d3
and that's a wrap what do you wish would
have happened in descendents 3 tell us
in the comments hit that subscribe
button to be the first to see our latest
videos and click the thumbs up button
while you're at it thanks for watching
the things we'll see you later
[Music]